what is a futurist tell us what is that
i would say that as a futurist my job is
to help people imagine
possibilities that some people would say
are unthinkable because they don't want
to think about them like the realities
of of the climate adaptation we're gonna
have to do
um or futures that people describe as
unimaginable because they just don't
believe that that kind of positive
transformation is possible you know i so
maybe as a futurist i try to convince
people that universal basic income is
not beyond the realm
of the imaginable that we could imagine
this economic policy being adopted and
we can imagine how it would affect our
own lives or i talk about geoengineering
people can't even think about
geoengineering as a possible
solution to
to climate change because we don't maybe
know enough about it we don't understand
the technology or the science the risks
the potential harms you know if we try
to stop some of the solar
radiation in order to cool the planet
while we get off fossil fuels
that may create uneven temperature
changes flooding in some regions how can
we make it equitable and safe so i try
to help people imagine things that it's
it's pretty hard to think about because
we've never done it before we've never
lived through it before and my
particular
you know process or methodology is
through creating games and and
playable scenarios so people can really
visit these features almost as if they
were virtual worlds where they could
look around and say okay what's
happening what's the new normal how do i
feel what are the opportunities what am
i worried about and we try to bring
together tens of thousands of people
to immerse themselves in the same
scenario at the same time so we can
we can share our points of view in the
future and also maybe get some data
about how are people likely to react or
feel and and maybe some of the
surprising social consequences so we're
not so caught off guard
by how people react to unprecedented
events